es gibt gerade jede Menge regierungswut
auf deutschen Straßen die den Kanzler
bei Protesten in cotbus entgegenschlägt
dass der Bundeskanzler vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr Volksnähe auch mal spürt
die dem Vizekanzler bei seiner Rückkehr
aus dem Urlaub auf einem fairanleger
entgegenschlägt die dem
Landwirtschaftsminister in elwangen
[Applaus]
entgegenschlägt es geht hier ziemlich
offensichtlich um mehr als bauernprotest
der Vizekanzler warnt sogar vor
umsturzfantasien hinter den
angekündigten Protesten steht mehr als
die jetzigen Regierungsentscheidung was
vor allem dahinter steht eine massive
antiampelstimmung die der Ampel
natürlich Angst macht die aber auch viel
mit den Fehlern und Entscheidungen
dieser Regierung zu tun hat also wie
weit geht der Protest und warum macht
die Ampel selbst gerade so viel falsch
hier unser inside politics zum antiampel
Bauernaufstand mein Name ist Andrea
Maurer ich bin Korrespondentin im ZDF
Hauptstadtstudio und beobachte intensiv
die Dynamik die die
antiampelbauernproteste gerade gewinnen
und die sich längst auch politische
Kräfte zu Nutze machen Hubert ewanger
etwa Chef der Freien Wähler und selbst
Landwirt es ist auf alle Fälle eine ein
Protest gegen diese Politik dieser Ampel
oder Sarah Wagenknecht die just in der
Protestwoche ihre neue Partei gegründet
hat mein Eindruck ist dass die Ampel es
tatsächlich verspielt hat bei den
Menschen man traut ihr nichts mehr zu
oder die AFD die eigentlich gegen
Subventionen ist aber im Angesicht der
bauernproteste kurz Hand ein
Sofortprogramm für die Landwirtschaft
auf den Weg bringt im Deutschlandfunk
sagt der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer Bernt Baumann es gehe
jetzt eben um mehr als Subvention sie
alle stoßen gerade mit voller
populistischer Kraft vor in die große
Lücke die die Regierung lässt denn
zwischen der Ampel und den Bauern und
nicht nur denen da tut sich gerade eine
riesige Kluft auf der bauernpräsident
beschreibt diese Lücke so noch nie
gearbeitet noch nie geschwitzt es ist
das Gefühl einer Entfremdung von denen
da oben die keine Ahnung hätten was im
Land
[Musik]
passiere kurz vor Weihnachten verabreden
Scholz Harbeck Lindner die größte
agrarkürzung der vergangenen Jahrzehnte
900 Millionen Euro der fehlenden 17
Milliarden Euro sollen aus den Kassen
der Bauern kommen mit Bauernverband und
dem eigenen Landwirtschaftsminister
haben sie vorher nicht gesprochen was
folgt es schlechte Performance der
Landwirtschaftsminister distanziert sich
von den Sparplänen seiner ampelpartner
und auch der Finanzminister lässt kurz
darauf verlauten er sei kein Freund der
Belastung der landwirtschaftlichen
Betriebe also quasi offen für die
Rücknahme der gerade gefassten
Beschlüsse für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger heißt das sie erleben wieder
einen ampelstreit eine uneinige
Regierung viele nervt das nur noch der
Kanzel aber bleibt erstmal hart um dann
nur zwei Wochen später zurückzurudern
und zusammen mit habbeg und Lindner
einen Teil der Subventionskürzungen
wieder zurückzunehmen Grund ist so sagen
es mir Regierungsvertreter diese Demo am
18 dezember in Berlin wo schnell klar
wird wie brisant die Stimmungslage ist
der wohl lauteste ruf an diesem Tag war
der nach Neuwahlen
neen seid ihr da um euren Frust auf
diese Bundesregierung kund zu
tun seid ihr bereit das über Wochen die
nächsten Tage
weiterzumachen sogar der Präsident des
bauernvereins also ein Funktionär
schlägt einen neuen turn an wir brauchen
eine anders
ausgerichtete Regierungspolitik wenn das
nicht kommt das sage ich so deutlich
dann brauchen wir einen
Regierungswechsel also unter dem
Eindruck dieser Bilder und der Drohung
ab
8.01.2024 das Land mit Protest zu
überziehen macht die Ampel einen
Rückzieher die Bauern bleiben von der
kfzsteuer befreit das Agrardiesel
auskommt aber schrittweise der Preis die
Ampel wirkt jetzt wie eine getriebene
die Beschlüsse aus Angst vor Protesten
kassiert wenn man lautstark protestiert
dann knickt die Regierung sozusagen ein
das ist eine Gefahr deshalb war ich auch
überrascht dass die Bundesregierung so
schnell gehandelt hat in der Richtung es
deutet vielleicht auch darauf hin wie
unsicher Mann auch in der
Bundesregierung ist die Ampel hat ihren
Beschluss also im alliltempo kassieren
müssen ist nicht das erste Mal sie hat
mal wieder Streit und sie erweckt den
Eindruck dass sie sich unter Druck
setzen lässt und noch einen
kommunikativen Sprengsatz legt die
Regierung sie redet mit den Bauern
einfach
[Musik]
nicht hat die Ampel bei der ersten
Entscheidung nicht mit den Bauern
gesprochen tut sie es bei der zweiten
Entscheidung dem Kompromiss einfach auch
nicht genau das habe ich den
Landwirtschaftsminister dann auch
gefragt nachdem ich gehört hatte dass
die Bauern wirklich sehr sauer sind dass
im Umfeld der Ampel Kompromissfindung
nicht einmal mit ihnen gesprochen wurde
ch ödemir reicht aber offenbar was er
auf der Demo am 18 Dezember wo er auch
war hier ein Foto gehört und gelesen hat
Vertreter der Landwirtschaft und auch
die Verbände mit denen wir jetzt heute
gesprochen haben sagen mit ihnen wurde
überhaupt nicht gesprochen schauen sie
war auf der Demonstration da habe ich
ungefähr anderthalb Stunden zugehört
also ich habe die transparente einzeln
lesen können ich hatte ja nun viel Zeit
und ich habe alle reden gehört hätten
die ampelspitzen einmal wirklich mit den
Bauern gesprochen hätten sie gehört dass
der Kompromiss nichts befrieden wird
weil es einfach um mehr geht ich bin
einen Tag nach dem ampelkompromiss
rausgefahren nach Brandenburg zu dem
Getreidebauern Thomas große R um mit ihm
zu drehen und zu sprechen und da habe
ich ziemlich genau gehört worum es geht
weil wir in den letzten Jahren sehr sehr
viele neue Einschränkungen und Auflagen
erhalten haben und das war eben der
Anlass jetzt der in den letzten Wochen
kam dass wir dann auch noch
überproportional für schlecht gemachte
Haushalte herhalten sollen auch die
Ministerpräsidenten scheinen übrigens
gerade parteiübergreifen zu kapieren
worum es geht um ziemlich tiefsitzenden
Frust übrigens auch die SPD
Ministerpräsident in Niedersachsen
Stefan weil im Saarland Anke relinger in
Mecklenburg vorpumn Manuela Schwesig und
in Brandenburg Dietmar wke der sich im
Herbst erneut zur Wahl stellen muss sie
alle stellen sich gegen den SPD-Kanzler
klar die Landwirtschaft hat in diesem
Jahr Rekordgewinne eingefahren aber das
Bild ist differenzierter es geht auch um
Strukturwandel Konzentrationsprozesse
wirtschaftlichen Druck groß gegen klein
und vor allem eben um das Gefühl zum
Spielball politischer
Nachhaltigkeitsprojekte und
geworden zu sein ohne gesellschaftliche
Anerkennung so und in dieser Gemengelage
geht die Ampel im Dezember nun also hin
und will fast eine Milliarde bei den
Landwirten sparen auch Ökonomen nennen
das unverhältnismäßig ich habe mich
schon etwas gewundert dass man einen so
großen Anteil des gesamtsparpakets einer
so kleinen Gruppe zunächst mal zumutet
das ist schon sehr überraschend ist es
klar dass wenn wir die Landwirtschaft
als Teil der Volkswirtschaft insgesamt
betrachen dass die Land Wirtschaft hier
einen weit überproportionalen Anteil der
Lasten tragen soll und dann ist da eben
auch noch auf der politisch
strategischen Ebene einiges schief
gelaufen die Ampel spart den
riesenbetrag bei den Bauern die bekannt
dafür sind gut organisiert zu sein und
Protest auf die Straße zu tragen Scholz
habbeck Lindner wissen doch wie
beispielsweise in den Niederlanden sogar
diese rechtspopulistische Bauernpartei
entstanden ist und bei Wahlen Erfolge
eingefahren hat also sie tun es trotzdem
und das ohne mit den Bauern wirklich zu
sprechen da müssen doch eigentlich alle
Alarmglocken Leuten meine Tonis eure
[Musik]
auch weil die Ampel 17 Milliarden sparen
muss wird es massive Zumutungen geben
mit Zumutung aber hat sich noch keine
Regierung Freunde gemacht und so
versucht der Vizekanzler in seinem Video
kurzerand die Schuld für den
verfassungswiedrigen Haushalt einfach
der Union in die Schuhe zu schieben die
geklagt hatte aber es ist eine Tatsache
dass die Union mit dem Ziel geklagt hat
dass Milliarden eingespart werden und so
fiel das Urteil dann aus die die
Konsequenz ist dass gespart wird also
erstens die Union ist schuld und
zweitens so habbeck in seinem Appell
müssen die Demokraten jetzt
zusammenstehen diskussieren Aufrufe mit
umsturzfantasien extremistische Gruppen
formieren sich völkisch
naationalistische Symbole werden offen
gezeigt in den Ohren vieler Bauern und
Demonstranten klingt das so als wolle
der Vizekanzler ihren Protest generell
delegitimieren ja bei den Protesten ist
die AFD durchaus präsent genauso
teilweise rechtsextreme Symbole und auch
der gealgen an dem die Ampel baumelt ist
immer wieder zu sehen aber
demokratieforscher beobachten eben auch
das Phänomen dass sich Bürgerinnen und
Bürger teilweise erst radikalisieren
wenn sie sich ohnehin in die braune Ecke
gedränt sehen und das ist zu beachten
wenn man eine so große Rede auf die
Demokratie hält wie Robert habbeck in
seinem Video der Protest jedenfalls hat
inzwischen durchaus Potenzial größer zu
werden das sagt auch der Soziologe Rolf
Heinze der als einer der wenigen in
Deutschland zu bauernprotesten forscht
und dann stellt sich die Frage wie weit
die Bevölkerung die Proteste mitträgt es
kann durchaus sein äh dass eine
sozusagen verstätigung des Protestes
dadurch auch noch genährt wird dass man
also eher durchaus sagt
wenn man nur hart genug auf der Straße
auftritt dann
werden auch die Politiker sozusagen in
Anführungszeichen weich werden das
Problem sehe ich durch aus es wird jetzt
davon abhängen was ich eben auch sagte
wie sich die Proteste entwickeln welche
Gruppierung dabei bleiben von daher ist
das schwer zu prognostizieren aber ich
habe daruf hingewiesen wenn diese
Blockaden und diese wirklich
antidemokratischen Haltung sich
ausbreiten wird die Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung schwinden die Sympathien der
Bevölkerung haben die Bauern bislang auf
ihrer Seite hier eine aktuelle Umfrage
aus unserem ZDF Politbarometer eine
deutliche Mehrheit sagt nein die
Proteste der Bauern gehen nicht zu weit
die Dynamik jetzt ist unabsehbar der
Kanzler hat eigentlich klar gemacht dass
der Kompromiss der Ampel das letzte Wort
gewesen sein soll glaubt ihr das die
Bundesregierung steht dazu die
Fraktionen werden wenn ich das richtig
sehe das jetzt Einbringen in die
Beratung des Deutschen Bundestages zieht
die Ampel das jetzt durch oder wird sie
noch mal nachgeben immerhin scheint es
jetzt so etwas wie Einsicht zu geben es
ist offensichtlich zu wenig miteinander
gesprochen worden und ich finde hier
muss man auch nicht drum herum ren das
muss geheilt werden was sollte die
Regierung eurer Meinung nach tun um zu
heilen die Wut zu befriedenen und die
Stimmung noch mal zu drehen kann sich
die antiampelstimmung überhaupt noch mal
drehen diskutiert gerne unten in den
Kommentaren mit und abonniert unseren
Kanal